[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل الزواياه هو من
جميع
نهائي المونديال والمغاربه يحتفلون حتى في
قلب اسبانيا
والسلام عليكم
ترصد خلطه نجاح الاحتجاج الوحده ودعم
ايراني الخارج
[موسيقى]
روسيا وجدت طريقا لتصنيع الصواريخ رغم حظر
الغربه لكن مسيرات ايران خذلتها لم تتحمل
الصقيع
وتتابعونا معنا ايضا
تركيا تجدد وعيدها لليونان وشمال سوريا
لكن التراجع مقابل المكاسب وارد واردوغان
عرابه
[موسيقى]
اذن اسود الاطلس اطاحوا بالمتدور الاسباني
وفازوا بركلات الترجيح في مباراه كانت
رائعه كنا كلنا فيها على الاعصاب حول فرحه
الجماهير المغربيه الموجوده في الدوحه
التي طبعا لا توصف يا ليث ليث بزاريا ينضم
اليناك من حيث يقام تقام هذه المباراه
انقل لنا الصوره من عندك
نعم ليال شاهدنا سويا ورصدنا الكثير من
امام الملاعب اثناء كاس العالم هنا في قطر
ولكن اليوم هو استثنائي احمر واخضر
باستثناء الجميع هنا يحتفل الاهازيج
المغربيه مبروك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
واقفا بامتياز الجميع سوف يحتفل في هذا
السوق الجميع شاهدنا قبلها قبل هالمره كيف
يحتفل المشجعون المغاربه بانتصار منتخبهم
وسوف نشاهد اليوم الاحتفال بالربع النهائي
يوجد الكثير من يريد ان
يتحدث.\‬ هذا بس هذا مش الانتصار للمغاربه
بس اذا انتصار للعرب كلهم وان شاء الله ان
شاء الله نتوفى في المباراه التاليه ما
بنعرف مين ينتصر ان شاء الله ان شاء الله
المغرب يعني من اليوم يعني من اليوم حتى
نهايه كاس العالم نتمنى المغرب
العرب كاملين المنتخب العربي الى المنتخب
المغربي اقوى اقوى منتخب في العالم في
العالم العربي والاسيوي الافريقي اليوم
هيتعاود من القرن ونصف قرن ونصف وعاش
الملك جامعه الملكيه وديمه المغرب
كاملين كاملين
الملك محمد السادس
[موسيقى]
اقفل 2010 كانت غلبه يعني فريق همم متواضع
الفريق الامريكي العض مراد بدي اسالك شغله
كاب
ختصر
تقريبا كل ما يفرقهم لما يكونوا في انديه
مغربيه هذا نفس الحال تقريبا بالنسبه
لتونس اتلموا لكل حول الرايه المغربيه همم
وقفوا مع فريقهم حتى في لحظات الصعبه ما
فيش كوني زفر او يسافر على الفريق لما في
حاله الاخ في في الاخطاء وفي نفس الوقت
هذا الفريق يتحب بصراحه لانه عنده فريق
جامعه موجوده التنظيم موجود والقلب موجود
لما تكون عندك الثلاثاء اي جمهور يمشي معك
وكل جمهور المغرب بيعادي
نعم
هذا نشاهده الكثير يعني ليال ممكن نقعد
ساعات ساعات على الهواء الكثير يريد ان
تتحدث ومن الفرحه طبعا هم على اللي حدث
قبل قليل في ملعب هنا المدينه التعليميه
او الديوكيشن سيتي ملعب هذه المنطقه وبعد
ذلك طبعا سيتجهون الى اللؤلؤه الى قطار
الى سوق واقف سوف يشاهد اتوقع الشارع
نشاهدها من قبل من احتفالات من اهازيج من
تراث مغربي من تراث عربي كمان شاهدنا من
مصر من لبنان ومن احتفل مع المغرب في
المباراه السابقه ولو اكيد راح نشوفهم
عندما سيحتفلون بعد تقرير اتفضل استاذ همم
الفوز فريقنا فريق قوي همم 11 لاعب محترف
لن يخاف من اي 11 لاعب مختلف من فريق اخر
يلعبون بقلب يلعبون بشاراسه
مخيفين لكل منافس الجمهور الرائع اللاعب
رقم 12 يعد من احد الاسباب كذلك الرئيسيه
لنجاح المنتخب المغربي جمهور رائع جدا
الظروف كلها مواتيه بلد عربي بلد عربي بلد
عربي بلد عربي
جمهور جمهور 40 الف متفق عربي لاعبين في
المستوى 44 و682
شكرا استاذ شكرا
للمونديال العرب يعني العرب يحبوا بعضهم
لدرجه لا تتصور انا لما شفت سعوديين
والمصريين والتونسي
احلى ناس وتحيه لقطر يعني واحد اللي قدرت
تعمل هذه المعجزه مدينه واحده العالم كله
في مدينه واحده
الحمد لله
انا كنت واثق المغربي انتصر ولكن عذبنا
عندنا فريق قوي قوي كثير وانا انا اقول لك
غيوصل للنهائي ان شاء الله ان شاء الله
اقسم بالله العظيم
والله العظيم فيها خير
وشركه مع مع الفريق المحلي
دوحه العرب اللي الحمد لله لم يعد شمل
العرب ونشكر له جمهور المغربي اللي حج
بكثافه لهذه الارض المباركه وبهذه الترحاب
بهذه الاجواء ما شاء الله لان صراحه
الجمهور المغربي ما نقلك انقذ المونديال
بس اعطى صوره حضاريه حلوه كثير كثير على
العرب كلهم وانا صور ثاني يوتيوبر فلوجر
صورت كل الجنسيات اقسم بالله كل جنسيات
العربيه كانت المحيط الى الخليج تحيه لكم
كلكم نحبكم والحمد لله من المغرب الجزائر
تونس ليبيا مصر
والخليج كله عرب نحبكم كثير وان شاء الله
الفرحه الفرحه الفرحه تدوم والروح والروح
ماتش ماتش ماتش شباب اه نكون عن عقليه
الفائز عقليه الرابح ان شاء الله ما في
مستحيل واحد واحد
ان شاء الله
قليل مدريد
المغرب الى ربع نهائي
كاس العالم اذن الجاليه المغربيه والعربيه
تحتفل بانتصار منتخبها على اسبانيا في
العاصمه مدريد
[تصفيق]
اول بلد عربي يصل الى دوري الثمانيه نستمع
قليلا الى الصوت الطبيعي وهذه الفرحه
[تصفيق]
يعني
مشاهدينا المنتخب الاسباني ليس منتخبا
عاديا كان يعني كان هناك توقعات بان يصل
الى النهائي وربما يفوز بهذه البطوله
ببطوله كاس العالم لكن المغرب فجاه الجميع
وافرح العرب جميعا كما افرحت قبل ذلك
المملكه العربيه السعوديه العرب بفوزها
على الارجنتين وتونس ايضا
يعني كاس العالم هذا العام مميز بالنسبه
للعرب في كل شيء بهذه الانتصارات المفاجاه
بانه لاول مره يقام على ارض عربي نذكر
بانه اشرف حكيمي الذي سجل اليوم هو مولود
في اسبانيا وخريج اكاديميه ريال مدريد وهي
كانت الركله الحاسمه في شباك الحارس
الاسباني اوناي سيمون بعد فشل لاعبي
اسبانيا في تسجيل ايا من ركلاتهم
اذا ونحن نشاهد هذه الصور
المباشره من مدريد يحتفل المغاربه هناك
بفوزهم على اسبانيا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كما يعني تعلمون العديد من اللاعبين
المنتخب المغربي هم اصلا لاعبون في
منتخبات او في فرق اسبانيا اصلا وبالتالي
يعلمون
ربما تكتكات المنتخب الاسباني ولديهم
خبرات عاليه
نذكر بانه الوقت الاصلي للمباراه انتهى
وايضا الاضافي بالتعادل السلبي همم بعدها
احتكما الفريقان الى ركلات الترجيح التي
فاز بها المغرب وافرح العرب بنتيجه ثلاثه
مقابل لا شيء
يعني المباراه القادمه من المفطرات حسب
معلوماتي ان تكون مع البرتغال او سويسرا
[موسيقى]
همم الذين
يلعبان الان
بيلعبان الان على ستاد مستيل والنتيجه حتى
الان سلبيه
[تصفيق]
كان المغرب قد تاهل الى دور ثمن النهائي
بعد ما تصدر مشاهدينا المجموعه السادسه
برصيد سبع نقاط من الفوز فوز الكبير على
بلجيكا وكندا واا تعادله مع كرواتيا
[تصفيق]
اسبانيا يعني دخلت هذا هي البطوله بسقف
عالي يعني كانت فازت باول مباراه لها
بنقاط عاليه همم ايضا
لديها سبعه كان كانت نتيجه سبع احداث باول
مباراه علت السقف بشكل كبير
ولكن يعني انا لست خبيره فعليا
بتحليل المباريات ولكن كلنا شاهدنا هذه
المباراه وامام اسبانيا كان هناك دفاع
وهجوم قوي منع المنتخب الاسباني من
التسجيل ان كان بالوقت الاصلي والوقت
الاضافي
اذا قعدنا الى التاريخ مشاهدينا سبق ان
خاض المغرب ثلاث مباريات امام اسبانيا عام
61 1901
كان توجهها المنتخبان بالتصفيه المؤهله
لنهائيات كاس العالم بتشيلي وفازت وقتها
اسبانيا بالمباريات المباراه الاولى بهدف
دون
[موسيقى]
السياسه في ايران اصدر القضاء احكاما
بالاعدام بحق خمسه اشخاص بتهمه قتل احد
افراد قوه البسيسه وذكر متحدث باسم القضاء
الايراني ان 11 شخصا اخرين بينهم او اخرين
بينهم ثلاثه اطفال حكم عليهم بالسجن لمده
طويله في القدير
في ايران ايضا وبين ما يحاول النظام
استغلال مذيعه عن حل شرطه الاخلاق والذي
يعتبره البعض شبه تنازل لاحتواء
المتظاهرين تتضح معالم التكتيكات التي
يحاول من خلالها النظام اسكات الحناجر
فالمصدق هو من اتبع النظام والمشكك هو من
صفوف الانتفاضه للاشك المحتاجون لم يصدقوا
تلك المزاعم رغم ان المدعي العام لرني
محمد جعفر منتظر اعلن ان شرطه الاداب
اغلقت صحيفه
ان النظام الايراني وتحت الضغط بدا مجبرا
على النظر في امكانيه تخفيف بعض قيود
الحجاب
تنقل الصحيفه عن متظاهره عشرينيه قولها ان
اغلاق شرطه الاخلاق محض تضليل يسعى من
خلاله النظام لصرف الانتباه عما يجري
فعليا من دعوات للاحتجاج وايضا يحاول
اثاره الانقسامات في صفوف المحتشين لكن
بكل الاحوال تؤكد المتظاهره ان الغاضبين
لن يقبل الا باسقاط هذا النظام
فالسيل بلغ الزبى والكره وصل مدح نشط
ايرانيه اخرى
تدعينا دائما
شرطه الاخلاق وعدته محاوله لنسع فتيل
الانتفاضه من دون تقديم تنازلات كبيره علي
الفنا الخبير في الشؤون الايرانيه يعتبر
ان النظام جعل دوريه الارشاد كبشه فداء
يسد به الافواه المنفذه منذ مقتل ماسه
امينه ماتت امي واشعلت معها فتيله
احتجاجات تمددت من المراه والحياه والحريه
الى اسقط نظام خ
وسنقاتل حتى الموت اذا اضرابات واعتصامات
ادخلت معها القاسي والداني في رب تظاهرات
[موسيقى]
انبسطي مبادئ الدين الى حراسه النظام
ضائعون وهم المدنيون ضاقت بهم الحياه ضرعا
بعد عقود من القمع السياسي والاجتماعي
فوجدوا من مقتل امين شعله لتفجير ما اختلج
في قلوبهم يوصلون الاضرابه لليوم الثاني
على التوالي في موجه تستمر ثلاثه ايام
بدات فيها الاسواق خاليه كما نشاهد هجرها
الباعه والمتسوقون علهم يفصلون صوتهم عن
طريق ضرب الشريان الاقتصادي لتلك البسارات
كما اضرب نحو 500 من عمال العقود العاملين
في شركه خزانات بتروك كيماويات في جنوب
غربي ايران
[موسيقى]
صحيفه دي جاردن البريطانيه حاولت ان تحلل
هذه الحركه الاحتجاجيه
وتتخيل الطريقه التي يمكن للشعب بها ان
يقود مضجع النظام بالتفاصيل سردت الصحيفه
بدايه هذه الانتفاضه ومع بدنها بالنساء
وكيف شملت لاحقا المواطنين من مختلف
الطبقات والاعراف وكيف تفنن النظام مع كل
مظاهره على مدار العقد ونصف العقد
الماضيين ان يقمعها بمزيج من القسوه
والاستغلال ليبدو في كل مره مدافعا عن
نفسه وطبعا تكون هناك نظريات مؤامره عديده
هي الخطه الاسلم بنظره دائما هذه الخطه
الاسلم هذه التظاهرات التي شبت في السادس
عشر من سبتمبر تبدو بحسب الصحيفه شبيهه
بالتظاهره التي اسقطت حكم الشاه في يناير
عام
1979 خاصه وان المظ رات تتجدد في كل مكان
من الشارع الى الجامع وحتى في المقابر فلو
افترضنا ان الغضب خف تقليلا سيشتعل مره
اخرى مع اربعينيه باربعينيه كل متظاهر قتل
على ايدي قوات الامن ما يعني ان دائره
الموت والوحشيه تتسع وفيات فجنازات
فاحتجاجات فقط لا اكثر من ذي قبل وتعادل
الكره الى ان تبلغ ذروتها
وتستنف قوى النظام وتهد كيانه
انتفاضه رواده عشرينيون يجرون ابائهم معهم
ولو بحذر فهذه المره تبدد الخوف ومعاد
لديهم ما يخسرونونه على حد تعبير الجيل
الجدير بالذكر ان هذه الاحتجاجات تختلف عن
سباقاتها كونها وحدت جبهه المعارضه
الايرانيه التي كانت سابقا شبه منقمه فكان
اكثر سهوله الامر الثاني ان الايرانيين في
الخارج كانوا لسانا يدعم المحتجين وبحسب
البيانات فان من بين 92 مليون منشور على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي 60% من هذه
المناشير هي من خارج ايران
[موسيقى]
تابعونا معنا ولكن بعد الفاصل
اسطول من ناقلات النفط حبيس والمياه
التركيه بعد القرارات الغربيه بحق نفط
روسي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في تطورات الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه قالت مصادر ملاحيه ان هناك ما
لا يقل عن 20 ناقله نفط في المياه
التركيات تواجه مزيدا من التاخير بينما
تستعد للعبور من موانئ البحر الاسود
الروسيه الى البحر المتوسط وسط تسابق
المشعلين لتامين عبورها بموجب تحركات
جديده لمجموعه السبع وفرض الحد الاقصى
للسعر برميل النفط الخام الروسي المحمول
بحرا بستين دولار انا كما اكدت مصادر
لرويترز انا 10 ناقلات على الاقل تحمل خام
كذاخستان سي بي سي تواجه اخيرا في الخروج
من مضيق الوصفوره التركي في اعقابه حاضر
الاتحاد الاوروبي على خدمات الشحن
[موسيقى]
اكثر من تسعه اشهر مره من عمر الحرب في
اوكرانيا استنزفت مخزونه الاسلحه لدى
الجانبين يتواصل البحث عن امدادات وبدات
معهد الابحاث البريطاني رويال يونايتد
سيرفس قال ان ذروه القتال في دمباز شهدت
استخدام روسيا ذخيره خلال يومين اكثر مما
لدى الجيش البريطاني باكمله وفي ظل عدم
وجود اعلان رسمي من الجانب الروسي تقدر
المخابرات الاوكرانيه ان الروس استخدموا
بالفعل
80% من صواريخ اسكندر البالستيه قصيره
المدال استهداف المدن الاوكرانيه والبنيه
التحتيه للطاقه اما المخابرات البريطانيه
فقد اشارت الى ان روسيا ربما استنفدت
مخزونها الحليب من المسيرات الايرانيه
الانتحاريه وانها تنتظر المزيد من الشحنه
الان وما تعثر الاقتصاد الروسي بسبب
العقوبات الغربيه تحولت روسيا الى ايران
للح قولي على الطائرات المسيره والى كوريا
الشماليه للحصول على قذائف المدفعيه
والصواريخ هذا عن روسيا علشان الجانب
الاخر تكافح اوكرانيا للحفاظ على تدفق
المعونه الغربيه من قذائف المدفعيه
والصواريخ المضاده للطائرات والدبابات
وصواريخ مارس وانظمه الاسلحه الحيويه
الاخرى
استمرار الحرب لا يشكل عبءا فقط على
الدولتين بل يشكل ايضا ضغطا على الصناعات
الدفاعيه في الدول الغربيه حسب ما قال
قولن كال نائب وزير الدفاع الامريكي لشؤون
السياسات اشار المسؤول الامريكي الى ان
الدول الاعضاء في الناتو قدمت 40 مليار
دولار من المساعدات العسكريه لاوكرانيا
وهو ما يعادل تقريبا ميزانيه الدفاع
السنويه لفرنسا في الوقت نفسه ينقص مخزون
الاسلحه لدىك صحيفه واشنطن بوست قالت ان
جميع دول النيته قلت قدراتها الصناعيه
الدفاعيه بعد نهايه الحرب البارده فمثلا
في الولايات المتحده انخفض عدد شركات
الدفاع الرئيسيه من احدى و50 الى 5 كما ان
شركات الاسلحه هذه ركزت على انتاج عدد
صغير من انظمه الاسلحه عاليه التقنيه التي
كانت مثاليه لخوض حرب ضد المجموعات
المسلحه لكنها غير كافيه عشان صراع طويل
الامل ضد قوه عسكريه تقليديه مثل الصين او
روسيا
[موسيقى]
واشنطن بوستنا اوكرانيا بحاجه لدعم لدعم
كبير لكن بعض العوائق تقف امامها القدره
الانتاجيه والوقت عاملانه يعيقان نسبيا
تسليما الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا لاسنادها في
مواجهه روسيا الصحيفه الامريكيه اعتبرت ان
افضل هل هو مساعده اوكرانيا على كسب الحرب
بشكل اسرع من خلال التزويدها باسلحه
متطوره مثل مقاتلات اف 16 والصواريخ
التكتيكيه طويله الامد اتاتمس وغيرها لكن
الولايات المتحده رغم المساعدات الكبيره
التي قدمتها لاوكرانيا الا انها رفضت مثلا
ارسال صواريخ بعيده المدى قادره على ضرب
روسيا لذلك تسعى واشنطن لارسال صواريخ
اقصر اقصر في المدام مثل بطاريات صواريخ
اوكرانيا ايضا لديها بالفعل بطاريتان من
هذه المنظومه
اما انا هالبنتاجون شركه رافيون عقدا لصنع
سته بطاريات اضافيه وتسلمها لاوكرانيا
ايضا من البدائل المتوفره بطاريه صواريخ
هيمارس واسلحه محموله من نوعيه جافلن
وايضا ستنجر بحسب واشنطن بوست جميع
البدائل ستكفي لفتره مؤقته فقط ولن تدفع
الدول الغربيه لاعاده تعبئه الصناعات
الدفاعيه خاصه وان توسيع خطوط الانتاج لن
يحدث الا ان وجدنا انفسنا في حرب عالميه
ثالثه
[موسيقى]
رغم التقرير الغربيه عن استراد روسيا
للصواريخ من دول خليفه الا ان تقريبا
كشف ان روسيا مازالت قادره على صناعه
الصواريخ المحليا
محققوا الاسلحه في اكياس وجدوا ان بقايا
صاروخ كروز روسي واحد على الاقل من طراز
وواحد تم استخدامه في هجمات واسعه النطاق
على العاصمه العاصمه الاكرانيه كاف تم
تصنيعه في اكتوبر وبعد اشهر من العقوبات
الغربيه الهادفه لحرمان موسكو من المكونات
اللازمه لصنع تلك الذخائر تم تصنيع بعض
صواريخ متوسطه خلال الشهرين او الثلاثه
الماضيه
خبير اسلحه قوله وان استمرار روسيا في
صنعاء صواريخ موجهه متقدمه يشير الى انها
وجدت طرقا للحصول على اشباه الموصلات
وغيرها من المعدات في ظل العقوبات
خاصه وان مخزنات موسكو من هذه المواد لم
تكن كبيره قبل بدء الحرب اصلا مجموعه
ابحاث بريطانيه فحصت بقايا الصواريخ
الروسيه التي وجدت ووجدت ان معظم المعدات
العسكريه الروسيه المتقدمه التي فحصوها
مثل اجهزه الراديو المشفره واجهزه تحديد
المدى بالليزر تمت صناعتها باستخدام اشباه
الموصلات الغربيه ومع التصنيع المحلي يشير
تقرير المجموعه الا ان الحكومه الروسيه
امره الموظفين في مصانع الذخيره بالعمل
للساعات اضافيه لانتاج المزيد من الذخائر
في وقت ماتت فيه روسيا تطلق الان عددا اقل
من الاسلحه بعيده المدى على اهداف
اوكرانيا وبينما يترقب العالم حرب الشتاء
قد يقف هذا الفصل في احد جوانب الحرب في
صفي اوكرانيا في حسب وزاره الدفاع فيك
مسؤولون عسكريون قالوا ان المسيرات
الانتحاريه الايرانيه
مصممه ولا تصلح لرد الشتاء خاصه وانها
مصنوعه من البلاستيك ومواد اخرى غير
مقاومه لتساقيع روسيا سبق لها ان استخدمت
هذه المسيارات لمساعده في الهجمات على
البنيه التحتيه الاوكرانيه وكانت فعاليه
هذه الطائرات موضع خلاف النائبه في
البرلمان الاوكراني ليسيا فازلينكو غردت
على تويتر امس قائله ان افضل ما في درجات
الحراره المنخفضه في اوكرانيا هو ان
طائرات شاهد لا تستطيع تحمل البرد يوم امس
ايضا قالت بس ان القوات الروسيه تستخدم
بنجاح طائرات دون طائرات تدعى تشون تقوم
بمراقبه مواقع القوات الاوكرانيه متحدثا
روسي اضاف للوكاله لان المسيره مجهزه
بمعدات تصوير حراري ورؤيه ليليه الاهم
انها تعمل في درجات حراره تتراوح بين 40
عشان يقويه وكمحد اقصى 30 درجه مئويه تحت
وربما يفسر كل هذا ان هذه الطائرات لم
تظهر منذ السابع عشر من نوفمبر الماضي
وقبل ان اتحدث مع ضيفنا نشير الى العواجل
التي ظهرت منذ قليل عن الخرجه الامريكيه
التي اكدت ان الدول عبر الاطلسي تريد
سلاما دائما وليس مجرد هدنا واتهمت القوات
الروسيه باستهداف البنيه التحتيه الحيويه
للاوكرانيين كما شددت ايضا على ان واشنطن
لا تشجع اوكرانيا على استهداف روسيا حول
ما تحدثنا عنه عن عجله الانتاج الروسي
المستمره بانتاج الصواريخ ينضم الينا من
القاهره احمد عليبه الباحث في وحده
الدراسات الامنيه والعسكريه في مركز
الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه
اهلا بك سيد احمد يعني كما ذكرنا عجله
الانتاج الصاروخي لروسيا لم تتوقف لا تزال
روسيا تصنع صواريخ
حديثه رغم العقوبات عليها وبالتالي هل
السوق واسع متعب وفيه ثغرات الى هذه
الدرجه كي تستطيع ان تحصل على مع
دقيقه الى هذا الحد على اشباه الموصلات
بهذه السهوله
يعني
المواصلات هي مساله معقده او شديده
التعقيد من اكثر من ناحيه لانه مبدئيا هذه
الحرب فرضت يعني نوع من التحدي للشركات
المنتجه بالاساس لاشباه الموصلات او
الشيبس لانه ثلاث مواد اساسيه بتستخدم في
هذه الخلايا او المكونات بتاتي من روسيا
واوكرانيا مادتين منهم اللي هي البلاديوم
والنيوم بتخرج بنسبه 90% من الجانب
الاوكراني وفي السي 4 اف 6 دي بتخرج ايضا
من روسيا بشكل كبير وبالتالي المواد الخام
هنا تاثرت الى حد كبير لكن كوريا الجنوبيه
قالت ان هي ممكن توفر البديل للشركات اللي
بتشتغل في ده وبالفعل ما بقاش في ازمه
كبيره لكن ايضا كان في يعني اعاقه اخرى
بتتعلق او تحدي اخر بيتعلق بمساله الرقابه
الامريكيه اللي في الحقيقه ما فيش تاكيد
على ان هي ممكن تكون فعاله بنسبه 100% وان
هو حتى لو في نسبه تسرب للمستخدم النهائي
عن طريق انه شركات مدنيه بتستخدم هذه
الخلايا فممكن ان هي همم تحصل روسيا في
الاخير او تقدر ان هي تحصل في الاخيره على
النسبه صحيح مش هتقدر توفى بالمطالب لانه
هي بتحتاج تقريبا حوالي 25 نوع من هذه
المكونات ممكن يتوفر لها ما بين 10 ل 12
نوع لكن من المؤكد انه نصف هذه الانواع
على الاقل لن تكون متوفره في السوق او
الوصول لها بسهوله وبالتالي ده بيشكلها
تحدي همم كبير المساله الاخرى انه ما
باتصور انه يعني ربما تكون همم روسيا
بتحاول دلوقت ان هي تستعد عن ده من خلال
البدائل الوطنيه ودي مساله صعبه كان عندها
شركتين في الحقيقه
بتنتج اشباه الموصلات لكن هذه الشركات
تعثرت ل- اا فتره طويله وما عادتش قادره
على
الانتاج اا لكن هي بتحاول همم ربما يكون
عندها مخزون قليل هي هتحاول ان هي تستخدمه
في الحد الادنى
للاحتياجات المطلوبه في الساحه الاوكرانيه
لكن متوسط استخدام الصواريخ لازال في حياه
الامر يعني
مرتفع احنا بنتكلم بمعدلات بتصل في بعض
الايام ل 60 ل 70 صاروخ وهي بتحتاج اشباه
الموصلات على الاقل في 11 نوع من الصواريخ
وبتحتاجها في نوعين من الطيارات اللي كانت
حاليا همم وبالتالي نعم
عن هجمات المسيرات الروسيه التي توقفت منذ
17 من نوفمبر الماضي همم وهناك حديث بانه
المسيارات الايرانيه الصنع التي استعنت
بها موسكو غير فعاله ما العيب فيها ما
العيب في المسيرات الايرانيه
يعني في ايضا اكثر بمؤشر في النقطه دي
الحقيقه لانه روسها ركزت على الطياره اللي
هي شاهد 136 في حين انه ممكن كان في انواع
اخرى تستعين بها لكن طياره رخيصه ممكن
تستخدمها بشكل مكثف همم بتستخدم كخذائف
متسكعه بشكل اساسي يعني ما فيش منها يعني
يعني ممكن تكون موجوده يعني تصل الى
الاهداف اللي هي عايزاه لكن هي يعني في
المرحله الحاليه مش بتحقق كفاء والدليل
على كده ان هي اختفت المساله الثانيه انه
ما اعتقدش ان هي قدرت تؤمن من عدد كبير
منها من الجانب الايراني خاصه الايراني
الموضوع كان يعني بشكل ضغط كبير جدا
والفرضت عليها عقوبات اضافيه بسبب هذا
الموضوع وايه روسيا رجعت لبدائل ظهرت
الطياره زي لانسس على سبيل المثال لكن
ايضا ما استخدمتش على يعني نطاق كويسه
وبالتالي همم روسيا عندها
ما تحدي في هذا الجانب همم الحقيقه ايضا
انه واضح يعني كما نشرت حضرتك في التقرير
انه في مشكله ايضا متعلق بالوضع المناخي
مع البروده الشديده اللي بتواجهها زيت
الطياره لانه هي بتستخدم اشعه تحت الحمراء
في المقدمه على المقدمه هذه الطياره على
اعتبار ان هي تقدر توصل للهدف لكن مع هذه
الظروف الجويه ما بتقدرش ان هي تقدر تحدد
بشكل دقيق الهدف اللي هي المفروض توصل له
بالتالي بتقل الكفاءه بشكل كبير فضلا عن
الخامات وبعدين سرعتها محدوده في حقيقه
الامر كمان وبالتالي العائق الجو هنا
بياثر عليها بشكل كبير فهي محدوده الكفاءه
اعتقد ان ما كانش في عدد كبير جدا موجود
منها مناسب لان هو يعني يستخدم في همم
مسافه في فتره همم طويله بهذا الشكل
والحرب لا تزال وبالتالي والرسل بتفقد
القدره على تامين انجازات النوع ده بالشكل
ده شكرا
السيد احمد عليه بقى الباحث وفي وحده
الدراسات الامنيه والعسكريه في مركز
الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه
[موسيقى]
بعد عاصفه من الجدل في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اكد الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
انه لا يريد الغاء العمل بالدستور متهما
ما وصفها بالاخبار الزائفه بالترويش لذلك
ترامب خرج بهذا الموقف بعد سيل من
الانتقادات من الحزبين الديمقراطي
والجمهوري لمنشوره على من قصته تروس سوشل
الذي دعى فيه الى انهاء العمل بالدستور من
اجل الغاء انتخابات 2020 واعادته الى
السلطه حسين الطود والتفاصيل
[موسيقى]
بعد دعوته الى انهاء العمل بالدستور
لاعادته الى السلطه الرئيس السابق هو
دونالد ترامب يتراجع قائلا ان الاخبار
الزائفه تحاول اقناع الامريكيين بانه دعا
الى ذلك مؤكدا انه لا يريد الغاء الدستور
تراجع ترامب جاء بعد سيل انتقادات
فالنائبه الجمهوريه
الدستور فيما اعتبرت السيناتور الجمهوريه
اليزا مركوسكي الدعوه اهانه للجمهوريين
اما مستشاره السابق للامن القومي فدع
المحافظين الى معارضه حملته للانتخابات
الرئاسيه
مستعد لرئيس يرفض الدستور بشكل قاطع هناك
الكثير ممن يتلاعبون بالقواعد بما في ذلك
الرئيس ايضا لكن اقتراح الرئيس ترامب
بالغاء الدستور بحيث يمكن اعادته الى
منصبه هو حقا خارج نطاق ما يجده معظم
الناخبين مقبولا
البيت الابيض بدوري يعتبر تصريحات ترامب
لا نعرف الامه الامريكيه فيما حضر زعيم
الديمقراطيين في مجلس الشيوخ شكشوما ترامب
خارج عن السيطره ويشكل خطرا على
الديمقراطيه داعيا الجميع الى ادانت هجومه
الديمقراطيون يفهمون بان دونالد ترامب هو
اداه تنظيم رائعه لحزبهم لقد كان كارثيا
على الجمهوريين في الانتخابات وهكذا فان
الديمقراطيين سعداء جدا سخيفه
ايلون ماسك الذي ساهم الى حد ما بمنشور
ترامب بعد اصدار تويتر ملفات تكشف عن
التستر على تقرير حول نجل الرئيس جوبيدا
انتقد دعوه ترامب قائلا ان الدستور اكبر
من اي رئيس
رغم تاكيد ترامب انه لا يريد الغاء
الدستور واتهامه وسائل الاعلام بمحاوله
اقناع الامريكيين بذلك يسر خبراء ان عليه
ان يوضح ويشرح ما كان يقصده بدلا من ان
يقول ببساطه انك كلامه تم نقله بشكل خاطئ
حسين الطاوض العربيه
زعيم والمعارضه الالبانيه تزعم مسيره
لانتقاد الحكومه فطلقت اذكارا لن ينساه
بعد الفصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا وصلت تركيا وعيدها في
اثنين من اكثر ملفات الشائكه في المنطقه
فالرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان اعادت تاكيد على
ان انقره تتخذ كل الاجراءات اللازمه
لمواجهه ما وصفه بالارهاب شمال سوريا
وبالتزامن كان وزير خارجته موليود تشاوش
اوغلو يهدد اليونان باتخاد اجراءات ضدها
اذا وصلت تسليحه جذورها في بحر ايجا
تصريحات شوش اوغلو تاتي عاقبه قريره عن
مناورات عسكريه يونانيه على جزيرتي رودس
في بحر ايجابي وتشدد تركيا على ان النشره
الجنود او الاسلحه في بعض الجزر القريبه
من سواحلها
انتهاكا لوضعها غير العسكريه وفقا للقانون
الدولي في حين تسع اثنا للدفاع عن الجزر
متهمه تركيا بنشر قوه عسكريه كبيره على
الشواطئ المقابله لهذه الجزر
طيب اردوغان الرئيس الثاني عشر لتركيا منذ
18 اعوام شرف على ان ينهي السبعين من عمره
وكذلك على امل ان يجدد عهد الرئاسه في
الانتخابات المرتقبه في يونيو المقبل
تراجعت شعبيته بحسب استطلاعات راي تشرح
المشهد السياسي في تركيا نصف المدنيين
اوضحوا انهم لن يصوتوا لاردوغان وبناء
عليه قرر ان ينفذ خطه الحرباء
الفرنسيه الصحيفه قالت ان اردوغان يكتسح
الساحه الدوليه بافعاله في الفتره الاخيره
ليعزز صورته الداخليه امام الاتراك الذين
بداوا واحدا تلو الاخر يفقدون الثقه
بتصرفاته وافعاله وقل ذلك من اجل الحفاظ
على السلطه ووفقا ما قال لموند فان
اردوغان يملك صفات الحرباء الفريده يمتلك
مواهب المراوغه بقدرته على تحويل الازمات
الى فرص سياسيه تجعل مبارك تتجه اليه
[موسيقى]
عشونا عاما من الحكم قدها اردوغان كرئيس
الوزراء اولا ثم كرئيس للدوله كل تلك
الاعوام بالصراعاتها ونزرعتها برز فيها
اردوغان مثيرا للصدمات تاره ومره اخرى
يفاقم التوترات ليخرج من ماء كاد ان يقضي
على سلطته فبينما يهدد بعمليه بريه ضد
الاكرادي في الشمال السوري انتقاما من
التفجير الدموي في اسطنبول منتصفه نوفمبر
لعب اليوم دوري الصانع السلام بين روسيا
واوكرانيا وتوسط مع الامم المتحده لفتح
ثلاثه موان اوكرانيه على البحر الاسود
لتصدير الحبوب والقمح وبالفعل اعلنت اخراج
اكثر من 13 مليون طن من الحبوب من
اوكرانيا ومنذ بدا تطبيق اتفاقيه اسطنبول
الموقعه في الثاني والعشرين من يوليو
الماضي حتى ان تركيا الى عدم حرق الجسور
مع روسيا والتوصل الى تسويه بين الجانبين
كما ان
حتى تاريخيه على ارض قطر تصدرت عناوين
العلاقات التركيه المصريه بين اردوغان
ونظيره عبد الفتاح السيسي كان قبلها قد
رفض رفضا قاطعا ان يقبله لكنه بدل لونه
اقصد رايك قال لا خلاف ابديا في السياسه
جمله قالها لمصر وكرر لسوريا مع وساطه
روسيه ليلتقي بالرئيس رئيس السوري رئيس
النظام بشار الاسد بعد ان كان عدوه اللدود
اشارت الصحيفه ايضا الى ان تاريخ اردوغان
حافل بتغيير المواقف وربما الايدولوجيات
استشهدت الصحيفه بعلاقاته مع ثلاثه رؤساء
سابقين لامريكا بدا من جورج بوش الذي راى
باردوغان المسلمه المتحمس يلهيب اوباما
الذي اعتبر علاقته باردوغان تفتح له نافذه
على العالم الاسلامي اما دون ترامب الشهير
بحبه للا اه فاشاد باردوغان وقال انه صانع
السفقه
[موسيقى]
تصريح اليوم مشاهدينا لا نرى فرصه لاجراء
المفاوضات في الوقت الحالي لكن نتيجتها
يجب ان تكون السلام العادل والذئب التصريح
الكراملين ردا على ما يبدو تصريحات وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه عن ان الصراع سينتهي
بالديبلوماسيه لمحل الكريم للاضافه ايضا
انه لا محدثات قبل ان تحقق روسيا اهداف
عمليتها العسكريه على الارض هكذا اذا
اتفقت موسكو مع اكياس ضمنيا لا مفاوضات
قبل واحد من امرين ان تتحقق الاهداف او
يصبح تحقيقها مستحيلا
فيديو اليوم زعيمه المعارضه الالبانيه
سالي بريشا يقود مسيره ضخمه في العاصمه
تيران للدعوه للانتخابات مباشره لكن اتاها
زائر غاضب من مؤيدين الحكومه على ما يبدوا
ووجه وجه له لكمه مباشره
اقتص انصار بريشا من الرجل ووجه له عشره
لكمات لكنها رسالته كانت قد وصلت بالفعل
وبقيت على وجه بريشه وهو يخاطب ان ساره
الله اكبر